hello and welcome to this video playing
I am soft rain and a Costa Rica okay so
what do we get the dragon yeah okay yeah
I'm not going to play the sharp line
against the dragon is simply I don't
really have an idea about it and I
usually just get killed if I try to play
the rouser variation of the dragon it it
just doesn't it's just a loss if I play
it so i don't i don't want to play this
more strategic line Karpov has played
this a couple of times in the 1980s late
70s early 80s when he was still playing
onee form on regular on regular basis he
basically stopped playing one year form
almost stopped playing one year for when
he faced Kasparov in all those matches
he had an excellent score with one year
form but not against the COS far off was
the problem so he always got got totally
smashed in them smash is wrong but he
never warned them against Kasparov
Sicilian so this looks okay for black
hmmm Jim if i take it rock chicks my
night still look silly there on deform
if i move the Queen he takes on everyone
that also looks kind of silly ok so that
was not successfully opening he's
threatening they're not really 94 is not
a threat yet but it's it's close
oh this is a okay mom yeah this is me
playing one year for okay okay yeah I've
look technically wrong is this why I
wanted to play the night but yeah so
let's see what happens here let's see
yeah porn down for nothing basically
ideas you five not very subtle I have
the same but still
I had also week this position la4 porn
sticks out a little bit
yeah let's see what he's doing Black has
many good options and this is one of
them
yeah I don't know if Bishop age six is
actually helping me to be honest but
it's really not easy to find some play
in a black structure is very solid
hold it right of the best tries to yet
try to hold some n gave up on down if
you can get down
yeah I know just before probably check
okay maybe I can do something against to
be fun if I go be three year i will
check probably
ok you can can do that or i would seem
i'm not even threatening the porn it's a
problem okay so that looks pretty awful
if I have 9070 threatening night c5 and
he threatens yeah it's pretty bad if I
take it my cheeks he's got 93 lined up
okay maybe I'm still this I mean it-it's
pretty bad but I didn't really see
anything good naya Queens you one night
f2 maybe of course he's winning with ok
I have to play play something
yeah i was thinking queen g 594 maybe
I have to go back now the i don'ts
didn't see a way to give up be two for
something real so maybe still with 94 I
can set some problems 9424 things like
that okay see if you find something
better now our this one okay can check
here it doesn't do much okay let's take
it I would like to go an idea for that
of course that's not possible Queen g3
is probably strong do this night f4 hmm
not sure here night f4 King III ok just
this one ok to text that time money on
here if I go Queen d2 i'm also losing ok
so let's do this check
Jack check here 95 doesn't really do all
that much unfortunately queen age for
Queen g6 chat still I probably have to
try okay just back probably Queen g5
Queen takes age five at least maybe I
can try try this check okay check now
I'm getting [ __ ] mated myself probably
check check Quincy one creature she is
made okay check check I've got no check
left check okay like 430-5 I'm yeah I
can that was pretty awful blundering
that porn Jan I'm not at home in those
positions but i wanted to vary a little
bit my openings i think this should be
kind of okay i mean i cannot be worse in
this position that would be kind of flip
of the strange but yeah what am I doing
here maybe a four isn't good maybe a
four isn't good yeah this night before
looks like it's comfortable for black
it's not easy for me at you to generate
some plain night to defy for example is
something that why would like to play
but doesn't work out and then this
definitely is okay
for black Joe area we have to move the
night I forgot so they didn't see the
tactic even though I have to say if I
have to play this back I mean black is
very comfortable so this opening went
went wrong yet yeah I more or less
losing i mean i don't really don't
really think there was much to do after
that check check Jim this also was no
help in here here that something like
that is just terrible for white this is
also terrible but yeah can still hope at
you to go on to those dark squares him
and add some slight hoops here when the
night was only for the check there is
nothing happening reject check no he did
a good job down and was very bad opening
yeah it's difficult to play the open
Sicilian when you have no idea sometimes
you have those games very really feel
like a complete idiot like this one ok
guys thanks for watching